il y a une nouvelle forme de racisme
antiblonc êtes-vous d'accord avec les
propos d'eddouard Philippe interrogé
dans le JDD sur le drame de crpol après
la mort de Thomas l'ancien Premier
ministre a affiré qu'il n'y avait qu'
avait une nouvelle forme de racisme
antiblanc en France et d'ailleurs j'en
profite
pour réitérer mon amitié aux parents de
de Thomas voilà et au village parce qu'
je sais qu's sont toujours dans le mal
et on pense à eux on les oublie pas
parce qu'on a l'impression que les gens
les ont oublié et regardez ce qu'a dit
Gérald daranin parce que d'abord
regarder la réaction du ministre de
l'Intérieur géralin qui lui aussi
confirme l'existence d'un racisme
antiblan regardez moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il y avait du racisme et qui
touchait tout le monde il touche les
Arabes il touche les Noirs il touche les
Juifs il touche la communauté asiatique
et il touche évidemment les blancs bien
évidemment le racisme par nature c'est
la peur de de l'altérité c'est le refus
de l'altérité et c'est la haine de
l'altérité donc évidemment qu'il y en a
un contre les personnes de couleur
blanche personne ne dit le contraire et
ne pas dire pas dire la
vérité alors est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Galin
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de racisme
antiblanc oui Jean-Michel euh oui moi je
dis oui parce que je sais pas je je suis
comme tout le monde je regarde les
réseaux à longueur de journée et je
c'est c'est ça pollue de de de vidéo on
voit des gens de toutes les couleurs qui
font preuve de racisme et c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas des
vidéos il y a que des blonds qui font
qui qui brûlent le drapeau qui qui
crient à le leur haine leur haine des
Français et cetera donc oui et je trouve
ne dire qu'il y a que les Blancs qui
sont racistes c'est une forme de racisme
antiblanc parce que je vois pas pourquoi
il y aurait que des des RAC que chez les
Blancs c'est malheureusement une un
drame qui est commun à l'ensemble de
l'humanité quelle que soit sa couleur
quelle soit sa situation géographique il
y a des racistes partout et dire qu'il y
en a pas chez il y en a que chez les
Blancs je trouve ça tellement débile que
j'ai même pas envie de d'approfondir
plus longtemps parce que c'est aprs
après c'est vrai que c'est évidemment
pas au même niveau c'està-dire que moi
je pense que effectivement il y a une
nouvelle forme de de racisme antiblanc
mais que on peut c'est c'est c'est
nouveau et on peut pas le mettre au même
niveau il y a jamais un blanc qui a vécu
du racisme en demandant de l'emploi ou
en allant chercher un logement et C donc
il faut aussi mettre le curseur au bon
endroit c'estàd oui voir ce qu'on voit
c'estd la phrase de pegy quand on voit
quelque chose on le dit effectivement il
y a une petite montée du racisme
antiblanc mais elle n'est pas au même
niveau qu'un ancien racisme qui est déjà
ancré qui est là depuis des années qui
est un racisme antiuif
antimusul pas la porte duemploi le
racisme c'est dans la vie tous les
jours qu Mme S
Mme syème dans système franais par
exemple ou Mme peut-être mêmeial moi en
tant que blanc je n'ai jamais eu le
sentiment d'être discriminé par exemple
bah comme on le disait à l'emploi au
logement personne va me dire que j'ai
des cheveux étranges ENF je ne vais pas
vivre des scènes comme ça tu habes dans
quarti de
Paris JeanMichel tu sais pas d'O je
viens d'accord moi je viens
de passé bah oui mais tu sais quand on
parle de quelque chose on prend toute sa
vie en exemple pas les TR dernières
années
ta le seul blanc écoute Jean-Michel dans
mon lycée dans ma classe j'étais le seul
blanc il n'y avait que des rebux et des
renois dans ma classe j'étais au lycée à
clichousbois on ne m'a jamais dit sale
blanc on n jamais touché mes cheveux en
disant ah c'est marrant cette matière je
suis désolé c'est parce que ça t pas
arrivé ça n'existe pas écoute je pense
que je pense que personnellement avec
mon
his très biensme non non il y a une
hostilité faut juste choisir les bon je
dis pas rien il y a une hostilité en
effet d'une partie de la population qui
des cas des choses comme ça qui vont
peut-être s'en prendre plus facilement à
des blancs mais moi je ne peux pas
utiliser le mot racistme d'accord ben
non parce que le mot raciste il est
ancré dans une histoire dans quelque
chose c'est pas d'ord
ronac ce VI dire Hugo Hugo j'entends ce
qu'il dit c'est très bien ce qu'il vient
dire ce qu'il a jamais lu moi non plus
j'ai pas été victime de racisme
antiblanc on' on m'a laissé rentrer en
boîte de nuit si je rentrais pas en
boîte de nuit on me disait bah toi tu
peux rentrer mais tes potes peuvent pas
rentrer donc je l'ai vu je l'ai vu moi
ça il a il a raison ce qu'il dit Hugo
mais d'un autre côté tu peux pas dire
qu'il y a pas il y a racisme il est
partout il y a des racismes contre les
BLS des racistes contre les rebeux des
des gens aussi qui aiment pas les blancs
parce qu'ils sont blancs et moi je vais
même plus loin je il y a même des fois
tu te dis il y a du racisme antirance
même des fois même la France elle énerve
les gens juste le fait d'être français
ça énerve les gens et j'ai regardé je me
suis renseigné j'ai est-ce qu'on peut
appeler ça du racisme et ben oui on peut
appeler ça du oui oui ouiou oui parce
que je me suis dit tu es en train de
dire une connerie et pour une fois j'ai
regardé sur internet je me suis un peu
renseigné ça existe le RAC
oui ça existe d'être pas content d'être
français d'avoir une petite une petite
haine des Français hité alors toi tu dis
hostilité mais pour le coup là on parle
de de ils ont été plus loin dans le mot
toi tu aurais préféré qu'on descende le
mot d'un étage mais tu vois quand tu dis
hostilité quelque part tu nous rejoins
un petit peu dans les oui quand tu dis
hostilité quelque part oui mais le mot
racist moi me gne oui c'est le mot qui
te gêne parce qu'il est fort mais dit
Jean-Michel nous on on le vit moi moi je
suis parti à la campagne ici il y a
beaucoup de Parisiens nous on le vit pas
on voit pas pas mais met la place une
personne noire ça me gênerait qu'on
utilise le mot
raciste je suis d'accord avec toi sont
condamnablis Guillaume moi je trouve ça
honteux de se servir de fait d'actualité
qui sont certes tragiques pour créer un
espèce de racisme antiblanc et de le
mettre sur le même point et au même
niveau que le racisme qui touche
énormément de gens qui qui a du mal à
trouver du travail à cause de ses
origines qui ne rentre pas effectivement
en boî de nuit comme disait Raymond qui
a du mal à se loger à cause de ses
origines parce qu'il a un nom de T ou t
consonance
dit
contraireme nelle gu gu quand quelqu'un
se fait tabasser qu'on lui dit on t'a
tapé parce que tu étais un blanc on va
dire c'est pas grave tu trouves du B
sont extrémistes ce sont des actes sont
dramatiques mais le vrai racisme je suis
désolé il
ex pas de
vraacac est-ce que il juge bien possible
qu'il y ait une forme nouvelle de
racisme laéé CH Oui Valée a été très
clair évidemment qu'il y a une
discrimination dégueulasse quand tu es
noir ou quand tu es arabe évidemment que
c'est c'est une évid tu vois bien que
aujourd'hui il y a une redistribution
des cartes et je veux dire ne pas le
voir en face ne pas le voir en face et
se voiler la face prouve que justement
tu es complètement déconnecté et tu vois
pas la réalité et Hugo tu restes très
jeune mais retourne aujourd'hui ouais
ben retourne aujourd'hui en tant que gay
justement j'étais mais justement c'est
intéress enant que je pense que tu seras
pas accueil de la même manière RAC for
discriminationad aujourd'hui peu importe
que tu sois noir que tu es telle
religion que tu sois asiatique que tu
sois homo tout le monde à un groupe de
personnes qui les détestent d'accord
donc en fait tout mond RAC on est dans
une société où alors on peut appeler ça
homophobie on peut appeler ça racisme
tout le monde tout le monde est détesté
on est un homme on est un vieux port de
privilège blanc on est par par les
extrémistes féministes on est on est une
femme il y a les misogyes qui dessus en
fait quoi qu'il arrive il y a toujours
quelqu pour nous détester racisme nimpor
comment d'êre blan en
France il pas marqué que c'est compliqué
d'être
blan s'agissant du racisme comme le
disait pegy il faut dire ce qu'on voit
mais il faut surtout voir ce qu'on voit
bien sûr il y a du racisme en France il
est bien possible qu'il y ait une forme
nouvelle de racisme ane il y a une forme
ancienne de racisme antinoir antiarabe
ou antiju aucune de ces formes de
racisme n'excuse l'autre elles sont
toutes absolument condamnbl il faut
lutter contre tout bien et qui qui a été
victime de racisme antianc ici il y a
pas de degré qui à qui on a dit sal
blanc casseias pas de
trava
r sur les réseaux je suis régulièrement
Insul oui de Sal
blche tu ouvres X et tous les réseaux
sociaux des blagues racistes que je
n'oserais même pas citer et des salles
noires il y en a à tout
bout sal blanc sur les réseaux sociau
tuçis une fois comp
cent le problème c'est que vous faites
un un top 50 et un H parade de savoir
évidemment qu'il y a plus de racisme
antioir
Suren je fais pas c'est pas parce que il
y a beaucoup plus de racisme antinoir ou
antiarabe ou antimusulman qu'on doit se
laver les mains et
dire Mo anecdotique il faut le laisser
sinstaller il faut pas lter c'est ce que
tu dis s racisme oui racisme RAC s mis à
l'écart en raison de sa couleur de peau
qui est mis à l'écart de la société qui
n'acccepte pas au poste important en
raison de leur couleur de peau voilà
tous les tous les travails les femmes de
ménage et elles sont très importantes
les agents de sécule ils sont très
importants aussi c'est qui c'est
beaucoup de noir et d'Arab parce que les
postes valorisants ne sont donnés qu'à
des blancs mais dites la
vérité exclu de la société en Rais sa
couleur de
peau alors oui il y a des blancs qui se
font insulter mais là où je suis pas
d'accord avec la phrase précise d'Ed
Philippe c'est nouvelle il y a toujours
des gens qui n'aiment pas les blancs
voilà mais
c'est blanc VI tu viens dire des blancs
se font insulter alors tu viens dire des
blancs se font insulter c'est pas du
racisme voilàop pas deg il y a pas de
degré non c'est pas comparable tu peux
punir un blanc qui se fait
insulter demander des noirs et à des
blancs qui VI de
R merci
merci téléspectateur s vous PL oui 71 %
voyez non 28 % voilà Géraldine était
dans le vrai euh merci et Guillaume tu
as pas bien compris en fait c'est pas
parce qu'il y a c'est pas parce qu'il y
a l'un qui a pas
l'autre il est parti mais il il a encore
de la allez on rrouve dans un instant
les Ch